hey i'm i'm going to show you some
amazing stuff
fox news had to spend the day yesterday
covering this historic record-breaking
heat wave in the united states
in europe they had to do it they had to
cover the story because it was such a
major story without talking about
climate change and the fact that for
decades now we are seeing more and more
higher high temperatures record high
temperatures extreme heat and extreme
cold and extreme weather events all of
which a comprehensive climate change
model uh would predict and uh expect
this is just wild wild stuff so let's
start with some of the images
that appeared on fox news and they don't
mention climate change they talk about
it's hot but they don't talk about the
relationship to climate change excess
heat
parts of us face warnings and advisories
major story on fox news no mention of
climate change drought monitor
exceptional drought arid conditions
carry tinderbox effect of course very
high fire risk another aspect of climate
change and how climate change can
influence
um
it can influence the amount of land you
have that is potentially useful for uh
growing food when these fires run
through okay we've talked about it
before drought monitor
uh dallas triple digit temperatures
weather conditions forecast to continue
insane temperatures in dallas dallas
including highs of 109 and 108 this week
all of these stories didn't mention
climate change once now i know it's fox
news i know it's fox news but still it
is notable that they go out of their way
not to talk about climate change let's
look at a segment this is brett bayer
from fox news breaking tonight much of
europe is experiencing record
temperatures as a brutal heat wave rolls
through the continent britain shattered
its all-time record with a reading of
104.4 degrees fahrenheit of course at
heathrow airport london's mayor says the
temperatures are causing a huge surge in
the number of fires in the city one
grass fire in wennington required more
than 100 firefighters to come to that
scene ferocious wildfires continue in
south and southwestern france more than
2 thousand firefighters have been
deployed there tens of thousands of
people have been evacuated nearly 750
health-related deaths have already been
reported in spain and neighboring
portugal more than 30 forest fires
around spain have forced thousands of
evacuations
many parts of this country also dealing
with record heat robert ray of fox
weather has specifics from round rock
texas which can't be cool
by the way remember fox weather is the
new fox news weather channel that's
that's a whole other thing where um it's
the
it it's the
version i mean listen i it's they do
some weather but it's the way to now
make weather political and we've talked
about that before as well let's continue
today good evening robert
good evening brett i found a little
shade here in the lone star state and i
will say over 100 million people across
the u.s are experiencing excessive heat
warnings not a good situation 60 million
of those people brett are in the lower
mississippi valley the southern plains
and here in texas dallas
the big d expected to be about 1 10 soon
oklahoma city actually did hit 110
degrees it's the first time since august
of 2011 and the state capital of austin
about 110 san antonio el paso even over
to shreveport louisiana right and you
see that big orange ball that is the sun
that is the sun folks do not be confused
that orange ball is indeed the sun now a
re
a reasonable question would be
is there anything systemic going on that
might be leading to us doing this every
summer every summer saying record high
record high never seen before
now you might come back and say but
david i thought weather wasn't climate
and you were correct an individual
weather event is not
the same thing as climate a single
stronger than usual unseasonably late
hurricane
doesn't really tell us anything about
what's happening with the climate but
multiple decades of higher high
temperatures
lower low temperatures unseasonably warm
unseasonably cold
stronger and more and stronger
hurricanes during hurricane season all
of those things not just one day
start to tell us about the climate of a
place and whether the climate is
changing so a weather event would be oh
a crazy heat wave in new york city one
time
the change of climate would be
every summer the average temperature in
new york city as well as the number of
days that reach triple digits goes up
and you observe that over multiple
decades now we're talking about a change
to the climate of a place that goes
beyond an individual event it's sort of
like the same thing i talked about it
was either last week or the week before
why is it that anecdotal evidence is bad
well it's it's not so much that
anecdotal evidence is bad when it's
comprehensively collected
systematized and used to ascertain
patterns but then it's no longer
anecdotal then it's how we gather data
individual anecdotes insufficient
anecdotes out of context anecdotes are
what aren't useful so
uh that's what's going on this is the
exact pattern that is predicted by
climatologists erratic weather
unseasonable weather records of
different kinds stronger storms drought
etc etc that's exactly what's happening
in fox news because it's fox news
doing everything they can
not to talk about climate until night
time and i won't even get into this but
then at night they started ridiculing
the climate uh change believers the
people that accept science with stuff
like
liberals shocked that it's hot in the
summer
which of course
kind of misses the point we'll keep
talking about it the heat wave will
continue and we'll actually have more
about this on the bonus show
many of us know what it's like to have
acne show up when we least want it to
you should have seen me in middle school
now i'm on camera and i really do the
best i can to keep my skin clear and for
that i go to apostrophe our sponsor on
the apostrophe website you just answer a
few questions take a couple pictures of
your skin and then you have a virtual
visit with a board-certified
dermatologist who will create a
personalized treatment plan they quickly
ship you the prescription medication i
can tell you that when it comes to acne
you're better off with a dermatologist
there are all sorts of different kinds
of acne that need different types of
treatment the over-the-counter stuff was
not what worked for me
apostrophe makes it simple and quick
i've had a great experience with
apostrophe myself you get affordable
quality medical treatment from a
licensed dermatologist and prescription
meds that actually work but i can do it
all on my phone i don't have to spend
hours in a doctor's office
my audience gets 15 off your first
dermatology visit go to apostrophe.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is in the description